I think I said in the first episode then
I found this game really easy to start
with now I think I said that before I
try building highways because oh my god
did I get lost and perfection in all of
these lanes that go in and out of the
highways even though this is obviously
not my first experience with the
highways I have meddled with it before
and I must say the highway well the
roads in general in this game are really
fantastic and I think it is one of the
most important aspects of the city but
it's also one of the most important
aspects to me about this game because
you've got so many options I mean look
at that I had two cemeteries and many
people in my city were dying and I
needed to get some place to hide the
dead bodies so of course I needed to get
cemeteries but apparently I was able to
build cemeteries underneath my highways
and apparently people are fine with that
I would never want to be buried
underneath a highway but for some reason
you can place buildings underneath those
things so might at some point if I if I
really had a lack of space over here
might as well elevate the highway and
then just place buildings underneath it
if that is actually a thing if it at
least works with a bit of overlap you
could actually do that but yeah this
general area is kind of a area I wanted
to have on the side because I wanted to
have some more houses but then again I
also wanted to have a park in the middle
not something that I did notice is that
this park didn't really raise the land
value as a whole as in small parts that
you can place as buildings raise the
land failure and make people really
happy but just in general leaving areas
blank and just placing trees in them and
parts and stuff like that doesn't really
help to actually boost your land value
as far as I can really tell that is but
you know it's still not the most
important thing because most of all I
just like the look of it I don't think
our city is really a city without a park
and I've mentioned that before in my
roller coaster can three series and I
still stand by that point and as you can
see I don't think I've really talked
about this yet but the names of my
neighborhoods in my city are incredibly
stupid I I didn't want to really come up
with anything didn't want to spend time
on that dance this trivial stuff it's
really all about the city building but I
decided to just call my city global
village and a more all of the name
hoods after cities in real life so the
the neighborhood to the north of the
river on the left side that big one is
called telling I've got a sucker on the
rep on the right side frankford is the
downtown area and Seattle is the new
area with the park there is indianapolis
in the right bottom hand corner and
there is Mannheim which is the
industrial area and then I think that
was actually that's kind of stupid i
think i still see that name The Hague
over there and that is actually soon
going to disappear next to that is um
another city which I think it's dallas
yeah it is so that's how my
neighborhoods are set up don't really
know what the real point to that is
although the statistics are actually
very nice to see and I like the idea of
being able to set up neighborhoods like
that in general it's it's not only it
doesn't only look nice and it's really
funny to see those names when you zoom
out it's also very practical at some
point when you need to see whether
certain surfaces are actually good
enough in a certain place so they yeah
that's really awesome and as you can see
kind of working on that highway over
there because this is so far I don't
have to use this highway too often but
then again I was also afraid that the
industry would cause many traffic
problems which they're obviously going
to do because i think that's happened
with everybody who's played this game so
far and i definitely want to avoid that
and as many ways as I come as I can
possibly do that so building that
highway over there I was hoping would
actually save me some traffic delays in
the future although not now because I'm
not having too many problems with that
industrial area the only error that I've
met so far which was quite stupid and I
should have definitely thought of that
is the fact that everyone who needs to
go to the industry needs to go through
the old town that I had in the beginning
so I think that area is pretty clogged a
bit traffic other than that it's not
really too bad but definitely need to
fix that at some point so that there's
also the thing that you know I like this
idea of having green energy and of
course haha is Scandinavian builders of
this game so plenty of green energy
option
is that you have here the only problem
that I do have with this though is those
windmills in the water and they just
look kind of awkward they're not really
good for the immersion into the game at
least not for me because I've never
really seen those things in real life
seems to be a bit too futuristic and
even if it was realistic I mean the
river is still full of stupid stuff that
I don't really want to have in there so
if as soon as I can really buy more land
as in many squares maybe even get the
mold I'm just going to get some fields
and place many windmills on that because
not only is that more realistic there
there is something i don't know i know
that many people complain about the way
that windmills look but I actually kind
of like it I can't like this see the
city and those win trails in the
background and be like hey green energy
i am i'm good at this I don't know why
it just seems like that to me and at
that point I didn't have too many issues
by the way with the industrial area over
there but not yet because i'm pretty
sure that that's going to happen at some
point especially when the industrial
area is going to get a lot bigger
because it seems like the industrial
areas have at least like three or four
times as much traffic as the other areas
and of course their trucks so also a lot
more annoying and much more well
spacious in that sense so that might
cause some problems in the future and at
this point i was confused as to why I
had that enormous office area over there
with so much commercial zones and I
still had a tiny sliver of demand for
commercial and that was kind of weird
because I felt like I had way too much
commercial in this already as of now but
it turns out that that's not really the
case so I was like okay then I'm okay
with that but the land value in
Frankfurt as a whole is not too great
and that's why I decided to build that
little neighborhood over there so it
would be more enclosed by rest of the
city and actually get a higher land
value like that because there's not
really space for parks or stuff like
that over there and oh god at that point
the entire part of the city became
abandoned because of electricity
problems and I still need to install the
mod which automatically abandoned
building
but then again I still don't want to
because it just feel like cheating to me
in some sense so I might actually
install it 10 episodes later because at
some point i'm probably going to need it
if the city gets really big as soon as i
run into problems i don't really want to
remove hundreds of buildings i mean i
understand that you need to remove
buildings at some point but that's
taking it too far probably speaking of
taking it too far those windmills were
definitely taking it too far and i
actually had the option to remove some
of them so i did and i'm actually going
to make another neighborhood to the left
side of that highway over there because
i'm not really sure where else to expand
but then areas next to a highway and
should definitely be able to expand
without any traffic problems and at this
point i figured that ok I've got the
downtown over there and but net right
next to the downtown is that weird kind
of sub urban area and that doesn't
really seem like the best transition
ever so decided to and a small strip of
well quote-unquote skyscrapers over
there and see what the area would grow
into and make this little area park
because it seems like there's not a lot
enough green stuff over there in this
city and I know there is already plenty
of trees and parks in this city but to
me it's not nearly you know I just love
parks like that but seriously I think
there are much more trees than you
people usually think in cities because
seriously many buildings have trees at
least either next to it or very close to
it and parks are somewhat common in
cities it's not like a city is actually
an extreme concrete jungle where nothing
lives and there is no nature and to see
even a single tree you're gonna have to
move kilometers out of the city and
that's definitely not the case and what
I think is also not the case and this is
something that you know it's my personal
opinion and I kind of want to avoid this
just because I like it but I were to
keep the high-density buildings of any
kind to minimum image city because I
feel like a city with like 10,000 to
20,000 people in it is definitely not
big enough to place many skyscrapers in
and I see so many people already doing
this thing where as soon as you get the
high density you're going to spam it
everywhere
and I must admit that's definitely
something that I've always done in
SimCity and any other city game for that
matter I mean well no other city game
for that matter what everyone else
really exists now the issue with that is
in SimCity it was absolutely necessary
to build high density buildings because
otherwise you would barely be able to
fit anything else into it and it was
really hard without making either the
Texas high or the expenditures very low
to actually keep a city without high
buildings running but in this game it's
almost the exact opposite because I've
seen many people go for the high density
buildings all the way kind of route and
then eventually you would end up having
traffic jams and other problems because
high buildings do bring problems with
them and for that kind of practical
reason I'm avoiding that bit but only
just because also because you know this
is this is still I not that big city so
it's not going to come with huge
skyscrapers at least not yet I am
probably going to do that in the
downtown area later on and this little
road finger is a completely ugly that's
what I have removed it and in the end I
just decided to go for a really simple
pattern with those and actually the
zoning was kind of random in this case I
was just like oh I might as well play
some high density so I place that over
there but actually in the end it does
look really awesome with the highway
with the flats next to it and some park
so I do I really do like that but yeah
that's it for this episode sewed thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one in which I'm going to do some
general improvement of the city